[Music]
don't be stupid news submitted by Jordan
na a or restaurant ax his bat get us
trippin by the reviewer
who hadn't even eaten Vera I don't know
you spoke Italian thank you a song kids
talk what was the description I was so
distracted by David TripAdvisor reviewer
reviewed something but but they didn't
even eat there the restaurant has back
at a reviewer who didn't even eat their
scooty what's Shh why do people review
when they didn't even eat that places
that doesn't make any sense I have no
idea maybe they think it's like oh if
I'm reviewing this place it's because of
my entire experience interacting because
they think it's their personal diary
yeah
and it turns out a lot of people give a
walk what did the review say so this
takes place in the UK and it's a
restaurant called Bowie and oyster
sounds bomb oh it sounds like something
seafood scrimps yeah so the interview
here they gave a one-star whatever to
provider uses one circle
it says empty but asking for a
reservation question right this is
subject now the review says we showed up
at 12:30 and asked if they had a table
for two the waiter gave us a attitude
and whilst they checked their book we
looked around and more than half of the
restaurant was empty we got turned away
with a sorry no tables available only
one outside at two o'clock excuse I can
only assume they weren't in the mood to
receive our money oh maybe they had
of Asians and there was you or maybe
they just didn't have enough staff to
cover that many tables all perhaps your
[ __ ] smells like fish you should get
the [ __ ] out of my business anyways I
don't know well they did say like sorry
no tables available until 2:00 p.m. on
the outside right so we did mention that
in the review so now the owners Nadine
and Simon they responded to this review
saying it is always disappointing to
receive negative reviews especially when
ourselves and the team work so hard to
deliver great food and service however
such is the nature of TripAdvisor and we
can always improve from constructive and
honest feedback to receive a negative
review for this is simply unfair you are
not advising future diners about your
experience of our restaurant you have
simply vented your anger and tried to
get revenge for us not having a table
available for you immediately when you
strolled in on a busy sunny weekend
without a reservation as you said
yourself we were already half full
at 12:30 30 minutes into our lunch
service where we had 80 covers booked in
with advance and staggered bookings
throughout the afternoon our trained and
experienced restaurant staff do not
expect to have to explain what we mean
by sorry we don't have a table available
until 2 p.m. to customers who have not
booked but what have happily shown you
our reservations diary had you asked for
clarification FYI we had lots of lovely
customers booked in for later tables go
off for a walk on the beach and a drink
and return an hour later for an
enjoyable lunch sorry that you felt the
need to rate your experience as terrible
and we hope that leaving this review
made you feel better oh that is very
nice I'm a [ __ ] genius dude check
this out okay
uber you could rate each other and
experience from driver 2 like what I'm
hearing
TripAdvisor Yelp all of these things
businesses can rate their customer and
customers can rate their business that's
fair because when you look on the
customers profile right if if he's
like four or five stars all the way it
may be one star average person if this
[ __ ] is a bad customer one star
from all these businesses what that
tells me is I'm not gonna listen to this
[ __ ] customer I don't care if they're
elite Yelper
they got one star from every restaurant
they go to they have bad customer
behavior or they should have different
tags you know like the elite it should
be like shitty or something like so you
know not to trust the Unser verbal hi I
tweeted that Yelp because I saw this
[ __ ] review and on Yelp the reviews
that are like one-star and if you
request like a what do you call it like
a review of a review right there's rules
like if you didn't eat that at the
restaurant you can't be [ __ ] putting
up a review up there if you have no
experience with that place I read one
where it's like this [ __ ] wrote about a
food festival right that we have a
couple booths on and they were like one
star me and my family were driving
around for hours we couldn't find this
restaurant and when I called nobody
picked up first of all it's a Food
Festival
there's you just told the world what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you are it's the whole
[ __ ] football field parking lot yeah
and then their it's their fault that
you're a [ __ ] and you couldn't find a
food festival and you thought it was a
restaurant and then you put a one-star
it's like what the hell that's crazy
but I mean Yelp didn't even take it down
even after it was requested so I tweeted
that Yelp and I was like come on man
this is [ __ ] stupid David they
responded thinks we're gonna keep trying
our best to clear up the system and I
was like why don't you guys let other
customers respond to other customers
yeah like if this was helpful or not and
then you can get like thumbs up or
thumbs down yeah yeah it's like was this
helpful was this cool was this funny
they have those right but what they
should have is the business shouldn't
have to [ __ ] respond to the customers
like sometimes other customers can
correct correct each other it's a
community like the comments section on
YouTube oh and Yelp other customer other
Yelpers can't you know it would be dope
if the business owners could also
comment back then they could be like yo
you didn't even you never been
restaurant you can what but not another
you but they're like a cap have a
profile list not on the business page
you know what I'm saying like my
customers paid this customer was so
obnoxious so people can go to the cut
like people can go to like freakin Paul
wontons page and see like every single
restaurant roasting the month [ __ ] out
of this guy anyway okay so I'm not gonna
trust what Paul wonton says from now on
yeah because there are reviewers because
I think like when you're a business oh
you do check that person to see what
they you know what their opinions are
and I've gone to certain Yelp reviewers
that just give one starts to everybody
everybody yeah and you just happen yeah
that person should be suspended because
they're just out there just to only get
people bad reviews
oh wait doesn't Yelp like automatically
hide reviews from you new pages because
I mean you might think it's like the
friend of the business owner or
something and so they don't show the
review they should do that for people
that are always negative like hide the
their review yeah I think like maybe
it's also to like you'll probably bit
off a lot more than they could chew it
they didn't see how much of a powerhouse
they could become into like really like
choosing whether a business lives or
dies but a lot of these places now like
TripAdvisor Yelp whatever like I mean I
use all these things because when I'm
going to a new place I don't want to do
that much research I want to know and I
want to know like a thousand people's
response to this one place it's it's at
the end of the day it's better than
picking up a magazine at a hotel and
being like ziplining this and that I
can't trust it it's like they use the
best [ __ ] pictures everything is all
perfect and [ __ ] you show up it's like
broken-down ziplines [ __ ] harness is
like all old from the eighties or
something and you're like oh [ __ ] I
don't know if I want to go but I already
got here because the hard thing about
that too is is that people a lot of
people too because of how easy it is for
you to disappear and be anonymous you
don't talk to business owners anymore
that's the biggest [ __ ] issue because
a lot of the issues that you could fix
on TripAdvisor stuff is stuff that you
could have talked to the management
about and they could have fixed that
issue for you on the spot but instead
what you chose to do was to go away
destroy the business online without
feeling any repercussions so before if
you had a problem in a restaurant you
just talk to them and they fix it for
you yeah that's it
or before you go ahead and tell
other people what their food is about
you should talk to the owner first so
you know what you're talking about
and I think - its psyche for you guys or
anybody out there that does this kind of
stuff you should realize how much power
you have you do have a lot of power when
you abuse it you actually destroy
people's lives and I think that's the
scary part about it I just want people
will talk to people you know I mean like
that's just it's just one of those
that's true because I read some reviews
where people are like oh my food was
disgusting
I can't even finish the whole plate and
then I paid and I left I can't believe I
paid $20 I'm like this is a [ __ ]
restaurant in America when you don't
like your food you can say take it
[ __ ] back and give me something else
I've seen that multiple times I've done
it a few times but like what's up with
you finishing your meal paying the full
amount and then going back online and
talking [ __ ] about the restaurant that
you never gave them a chance to fix it
maybe they feel like there's a bigger
person I don't know but that's not our
restaurant culture here that's like
breaking up with someone without giving
them a chance to make it up yeah but you
know and if there's those restaurants
that you ask them take it back and then
that's a [ __ ] issue you know I mean
yeah then then that's where you're like
what the [ __ ] have a covers it doesn't
work out then go ahead and get van right
that reviews you know just give people a
chance is what I'm saying because I
don't know who you were at that
restaurant in Hawaii and we were hella
judgment in this white lady cuz when she
got her fish right and then she took it
back and we're like damn man why people
were picky
she got her other thing she took it back
they brought her some [ __ ] fried
shrimp Vince didn't believe her taste
buds he got the fish and he was like oh
it was dry ass Wow I got the steak the
restaurant here it looked cool and it
looked nice but the [ __ ] food was
garbage I [ __ ] took a bite of that
[ __ ] and I was like I'm so sorry white
lady you are so right what you what you
did was right this [ __ ] this food
shouldn't be [ __ ] this price and it
shouldn't be coming out like three hours
later give that [ __ ] back
[Music]